- Well, I, you know,
I got to hang out with my children
because we came off the road.
So I have a five-year-old
and a three-year-old,
so I really got to, you
know, connect with them,
which was really nice,
because like two weeks before
this whole thing happened
and we stopped working,
my daughter told me that she
loves when I come to visit,
which really hit home.
So it's nice to
- Oh, God!
actually be a father
and not feel like an
uncle in my own house.
So that was good.
And then I popped into high school Zooms.
Like there was, there was Zoom classes,
and I secretly went out on
Instagram and I would...
I like hooked up with teachers
and said give me the login
and I'll pop into these high school Zooms,
'cause I know how hard it was
for the teachers and the kids.
So it was a fun surprise.
I would pretend to be a kid
messing around in the class
and then they would realize who I was,
and it'd be a nice surprise
for everybody.
- Oh, that's so cool!
Putting my children are nice.